cet apiculteur constate les dégâts la
sécheresse et la canicule en détruit une
partie de la végétation
c'est de l'aubépine allait complètement
grillé n'y a pas de fleurs ya pas eu
peur il ya donc pas de fleurs pas de
nectar pas de nectar pas de miel savoir
que quand les abeilles récolte de nectar
pour faire le miel le nectar c'est 80%
d'eau donc si c'est sec et pas de nectar
résultats cet été sa production de miel
a chuté de 60% par rapport à l'année
dernière
pire encore au printemps - 75% en cause
l'alternance des journées chaudes et
froides même constat pour cet autre
apiculteurs dominique est un habitué du
marché de blois chez lui a choisi ses
abeilles ont également souffert de la
chaleur
et pour survivre elles ont mis au point
un système d j'ai un point d'eau qui est
pas très loin donc une mare sur trois
ans je n'ai jamais vu autant aller sur
le point d'eau elles étaient en rang
d'oignon et puis donc je me suis rendu
compte que est ramené de l'eau pourquoi
parce que la température qui était au
delà de 40 degrés alors au soleil on
n'en parle même pas c'était 45 degrés
elles ont ramené de l'eau elles ont
ventilé pour en fin de compte rafraîchir
l'intérieur on a aussi une baisse de
production c'est qu'elles ont utilisé ce
temps là pour rafraîchir mais pas pour
ramener aussi du nectar
enfin maigre consolation pour les
professionnels du secteur
les fortes chaleurs de l'été ont éloigné
les frelons asiatiques responsable de la
destruction d'abeilles les premiers
viennent seulement d'arriver en
loir-et-cher et leur impact devrait être
beaucoup moins important que les années
précédentes